bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'inflation alors non pas l'inflation
monétaire même si c'est une question
importante mais l'inflation cosmique
l'inflation cosmique c'est un phénomène
étonnant qui aurait eu lieu dans les
tous premiers instants du Big Bang et
qui expliquerait certaines des
caractéristiques étonnantes de notre
univers
l'inflation c'est le fait que pendant un
temps incroyablement court 10 puissance
moins 33 secondes l'univers aurait vu sa
taille augmentée d'un facteur 10
puissance 27 ça veut dire qu'il serait
devenu un milliard de milliards de
milliards de fois plus gros en un
millionième de milliardième de
milliardième de milliardième de seconde
ça donne le vertige non alors voyons
ensemble comment et pourquoi l'inflation
cosmique se serait produite
[Musique]
le meilleur modèle dont on dispose
aujourd'hui pour expliquer l'histoire et
l'évolution de l'Univers c'est le modèle
du Big Bang et contrairement à ce qu'on
entend parfois ce modèle n'est pas juste
une théorie il a de nombreuses
confirmations expérimentales très
solides on peut citer notamment le
décalage vers le rouge des galaxies qui
témoignent de l'expansion de l'Univers
ou encore le rayonnement fossile qui est
une sorte de photo de l'état de
l'univers tel qu'il était 300000 ans
après le Big Bang j'ai déjà parlé de ces
différents sujets dans des vidéos
précédentes et j'ai toujours insisté le
modèle du Big Bang est très très bien
corroboré par ces observations et
pourtant dans sa version initiale ce
modèle a quand même quelques petits
problèmes et c'est pour régler ces
problèmes que dans les années 70 et 80
des physiciens comme Alexey starobbinsky
Alan gut et André Linder ont proposé d'y
ajouter un ingrédient le concept
d'inflation cosmique mais avant de
plonger là dedans revoyons d'abord les
bases de ce qui constitue le modèle du
Big Bang
si on devait raconter l'histoire de
l'Univers avec une seule courbe ce
serait celle-ci alors attendez pas de
panique je vais réexpliquer
tranquillement ce que ça veut dire sur
l'axe horizontal vous avez le temps
exprimé en milliards d'années le temps
présent c'est ici par convention on le
note T = 0 avant c'est le passé et après
c'est l'avenir
alors vous le savez le modèle du Big
Bang nous dit que l'univers est en
expansion qu'il grossit donc et que dans
le passé au contraire il était plus
contracté sur lui-même donc on pourrait
être tenté de penser que cette courbe
que je vous trace ici représente
simplement l'évolution de la taille de
l'univers en fonction du temps mais non
ça n'est pas tout à fait ça on ne
connaît pas la taille de l'univers et ça
se trouve il est même infini cette
quantité n'est pas exactement la taille
mais ce qu'on appelle le facteur
d'échelle le facteur d'échelle on peut
dire en gros que c'est la taille de
l'univers à un instant T mais par
rapport à sa taille actuelle
regardez ici au moment présent a T = 0
le facteur d'échelle vaut 1 aujourd'hui
l'univers a la taille qu'il a dans le
futur ce facteur augmente car l'univers
va s’étendre et dans le passé le facteur
est plus petit que 20 par exemple on
voit qu'il y a 8 milliards d'années il
valait 0,5 ce qui signifie que l'Univers
était si on veut deux fois plus petit
qu'aujourd'hui
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire deux
fois plus petit puisqu'on a dit qu'on ne
sait même pas si l'univers est fini ou
infini et bien il ne faut pas
l'interpréter comme une taille mais
comme l'évolution des distances dans
l'univers par exemple entre les
différentes galaxies imaginons une
galaxie qui serait située aujourd'hui à
2 milliards d'années-lumière de nous il
y a 8 milliards d'années puisque le
facteur d'échelle était de 0,5 ça veut
dire qu'elle n'était qu'à la moitié
c'est-à-dire un milliard
d'années-lumière de nous inversement
dans disons 6 milliards d'années le
facteur d'échelle sera 1,5 donc la
galaxie sera à 3 milliards
d'années-lumière de nous la courbe
d'évolution du facteur d'échelle permet
donc de reconstituer l'histoire de
l'expansion de l'Univers en quantifiant
la dilatation des distances
et ce qu'on voit d'étonnant sur cette
courbe c'est que le facteur d'échelle
diminue quand on remonte dans le passé
et semblait valoir 0 il y a 13,8
milliards d'années environ et c'est
cette période qu'on appelle le Big Bang
alors attention comme je dis souvent on
ne peut pas vraiment parler d'un son
zéro on peut juste dire qu'il y a 13,8
milliards d'années l'univers était dans
un état extrêmement contracté et donc
très dense et très chaud et ce sont
d'ailleurs les conséquences de cet état
qu'on peut observer aujourd'hui par
exemple avec le rayonnement fossile
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé
vraiment dans les tous premiers instants
il faudrait combiner la cosmologie et la
théorie quantique et ça j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler plusieurs fois
c'est compliqué et donc on ne peut pas
en dire grand-chose aujourd'hui
bien excepté la question des tous
premiers instants la courbe du facteur
d'échelle nous permet donc de
reconstituer notamment l'évolution de la
distance entre les galaxies mais elle
nous donne également une autre info très
importante le rythme auquel les galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres et oui
ce rythme d'éloignement à un instant T
c'est tout simplement la pente de la
courbe ici par exemple à l'instant
présent on voit que le facteur d'échelle
est en train d'augmenter ce qui signifie
que les galaxies s'éloignent les unes
des autres et la pente de la courbe
permet de savoir à quelle vitesse ça se
produit pour deux galaxies données
la valeur numérique de cette pente c'est
la fameuse constante de Hubble qu'on
note généralement H0 la vitesse
d'éloignement sera d'autant plus grande
que les galaxies sont lointaines et H0
c'est le facteur de proportionnalité
si on regarde l'évolution de la pente de
la courbe au cours du temps on voit que
dans le passé notamment très proche du
Big Bang elle était plus raide donc le
rythme de l'expansion était plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui et dans le futur
également elle va finir par se rédire à
nouveau de plus en plus d'ailleurs et ça
c'est à cause de l'expansion accélérée
de l'univers qu'on attribue aujourd'hui
à ce qu'on appelle l'énergie noire ou
l'énergie sombre
alors très bien je suis en train de vous
décrire le passé et le destin de
l'univers à partir de ma courbe
d'évolution du facteur d'échelle mais je
vous ai même pas expliquer d'où elle
sort cette courbe comment on la trace
d'où vient sa forme et bien c'est une
application de la théorie de la
relativité générale au cas de l'univers
tout entier relativité générale il y a
une équation centrale celle équation
d'Einstein cette équation un peu obscure
nous dit en gros que la courbure de
l'espace-temps dépend de son contenu en
matière et en énergie
alors l'équation d'Einstein est très
compliqué à résoudre en général mais en
l'appliquant au cas de l'univers entier
avec quelques hypothèses
simplificatrices on tombe sur une
équation beaucoup plus simple qui décrit
justement l'évolution du facteur
d'échelle au cours du temps en résolvant
cette équation on peut tracer la courbe
associée il y a quand même quelques
paramètres dans l'équation comme la
constante de Hubble H0 c'est-à-dire la
pente actuelle de la courbe et il faut
aussi connaître la densité actuelle
d'énergie contenue dans l'univers soit
sous la forme de matière ordinaire ou de
matière noire soit sous la forme
d'énergie sombre
une fois qu'on connaît les valeurs pour
ces différents paramètres on peut tracer
la courbe que je vous ai montré et comme
je vous l'ai dit tout ça marche hyper
bien on a de nombreuses confirmations
expérimentales de ce scénario et des
estimations assez précises des
paramètres tout ça grâce à plusieurs
observations astrophiques indépendantes
mais il y a tout de même un petit
problème avec le modèle du Big Bang tel
que je voulais présenter c'est la
question de la forme globale de
l'univers on l'a dit l'équation
d'Einstein fait intervenir la courbure
de l'espace-temps et dans la courbure de
l'espace-temps il y a en particulier la
courbure de l'espace tout court qui
détermine la forme globale de l'univers
il y a trois cas possibles soit l'espace
a globalement une courbure positive on
parle d'univers sphérique et fermée dans
ce cas l'univers serait de taille finie
soit la courbure spatiale est négative
on parle d'univers hyperbolique et
ouvert on pourrait voir plutôt sa forme
comme celle d'une sorte de Pringles
infinie et enfin dernière possibilité
juste entre les deux si la courbure
spatiale est globalement nulle on dit
que l'univers est plat et dans ce cas il
serait également infini à noter que je
vous mets des petits dessins qui
représente ces trois cas pour des
surfaces en deux dimensions mais c'est
purement illustratif puisque notre
univers a trois dimensions d'espace donc
c'est difficile à représenter bien
maintenant comment on fait pour
identifier dans lequel des trois cas on
se trouve nous dans l'univers qui est le
nôtre est-ce qu'on vit dans un univers
sphérique et donc de taille finie ou
hyperbolique et infinie c'est important
comme question non et bien pour le
savoir il faut regarder les paramètres
de l'équation d'Einstein
je l'ai évoqué l'équation d'Einstein
nous dirige en gros courbure
d'espace-temps égale contenu en matière
et énergie or dans notre cas simple la
courbure d'espace-temps peut être
décomposée en une partie qui représente
la courbure temporelle et une autre la
courbure spatiale
la courbure temporelle ça peut paraître
bizarre comme notions mais elle est liée
à la constante de Hubble schématise
beaucoup mais la constante de Hubble
représente la vitesse d'expansion de
l'univers et on peut interpréter ça
comme une courbure temporelle
donc vous voyez que si on connaît la
quantité de matière et d'énergie
actuellement présente et qu'on connaît
la valeur de la constante de Hubble et
bien on peut par soustraction en déduire
la partie qui nous manque la courbure
spatiale et donc connaître la forme de
l'univers et il y a donc trois cas
possibles s'il y a beaucoup de matières
énergies par rapport à la valeur de H0
la courbure spatiale sera positive et
l'univers sera donc sphérique et de
taille finie si au contraire il y a trop
peu de matières et d'énergie par rapport
à H0 la courbure sera négative univers
hyperbolique de taille infinie et enfin
si la densité de matière énergie est
égale pile à la bonne valeur par rapport
à H0 et bien la courbure sera nulle et
on sera dans un univers plat
vous voyez que pour savoir dans quelle
situation on se trouve tout dépend de la
quantité de matière et d'énergie par
rapport à la constante de Hubble il y a
un seuil critique de densité si on est
au-dessus c'est sphérique en dessous
hyperbolique pile à la valeur critique
univers plan on peut calculer ce seuil
critique à partir de H0 et la valeur
numérique correspond environ à l'énergie
de 5 protons par mètre cube c'est ça la
frontière entre les casses féérique et
hyperboliques la question c'est donc de
savoir si nous dans notre univers on est
au dessus ou en dessous de cette valeur
de densité
alors pour le savoir on va parler
compter les protons dans l'espace
intersidéral les valeurs de densité de
matière et d’énergie peuvent être
estimés par des observations
astrophysiques comme les mesures du
rayonnement cosmologique je vous ai mis
ici le décompte des densités d'énergie
l'unité se le Joule par mètre cube et
pour faire plus simple on a pris
l'habitude de les exprimer en fraction
de la densité critique la matière
ordinaire ça fait environ 1/20 de la
densité critique donc sa valeur c'est
0,05 fois la densité critique la matière
noire il y en a à peu près 0,27 et
l'énergie sombre représente environ 0,68
fois la densité critique donc question
est-ce qu'au total on est au-dessus ou
en dessous de la densité critique et ben
voyons donc si on fait le total des
trois composantes ah bah c'est fou quand
on ajoute les trois on a pile la valeur
de la densité critique avec un coup de
bol
alors ok nous estimations sont précises
à environ 1% mais ça veut dire qu'on
peut considérer que la quantité totale
de matière et d'énergie présente dans
l'univers et comprise entre les 0,99 et
1,0 une fois la densité critique donc on
ne sait pas si on est au dessus ou en
dessous
c'est bizarre quand même non se dire que
dans l'univers il y a pile la quantité
d'énergie nécessaire pour qu'on soit
dans un espace plat on pourrait
l'accepter simplement dire qu'on est
tombé dans un univers qui avait cette
valeur pile à 1% près et ce genre
d'arguments invoquer un coup de bol en
sciences on n'aime pas trop quand même
et puis je vous passe les détails mais
la situation est encore pire si on
regarde dans le passé pour qu'on ait ça
aujourd'hui la bonne valeur à 1% près il
aurait fallu qu'au premier instant du
Big Bang la quantité de matière et
d'énergie soit réglée à un facteur 10
puissance moins 64 près pour s'assurer
qu'on est cette valeur aujourd'hui
ce que cet argument nous dit c'est que
en principe il y aurait dû y avoir
aucune chance pour que l'univers soit si
plat aujourd'hui et pourtant il l'est et
c'est donc cela le premier problème du
modèle du Big Bang pourquoi l'univers
est-il si plat alors qu'il devrait pas
en soi c'est déjà embêtant mais on va
voir maintenant un autre problème qui
semble du même genre pourquoi l'univers
est-il si homogène
[Musique]
un truc important qu'on constate quand
on fait des observations astrophysiques
c'est que les choses ont l'air d'être
globalement
identique quel que soit la région de
l'univers qu'on regarde les galaxies ont
l'air du même genre agencés de la même
façon et il y en a la même quantité
approximativement et donc à grande
échelle en tout cas l'univers semble
tout à fait homogène et c'est même
encore plus flagrant avec le rayonnement
fossile le rayonnement fossile on en a
parlé c'est un rayonnement
électromagnétique émis environ 300 000
ans après le Big Bang et ce rayonnement
baigne aujourd'hui l'ensemble de
l'univers nous en arrive de tous les
côtés et quel que soit la direction
qu'on regarde ce rayonnement semble
toujours presque exactement le même ce
qu'on mesure c'est ça température et
elle est de 2,725 Kelvin c'est très
précis et d'une direction à l'autre elle
varie de moins d'un millième de Kelvin
et il a fallu des appareils et des
méthodes très sophistiquées pour arriver
à distinguer ces variations minuscules
qu'on représente ici en couleur
une température de rayonnement à ce
point identique dans toutes les
directions ça semble indiquer qu'il y a
300 000 ans quand ce rayonnement a été
émis l'univers était déjà extrêmement
homogène et ça en fait c'est un peu
bizarre généralement quand on a une
température homogène par exemple c'est
qu'elle a eu le temps et la possibilité
de se loger pensez à la température dans
une pièce qui est initialement froide
d'un côté et chaude de l'autre il faut
du temps pour que l'homogénéisation de
température se produise et puis surtout
il faut qu'il y ait une possibilité
d'échanges thermique si vous vous isolez
les deux parties pas de transfert de
chaleur et donc pas d'homogénéisation et
ce qui est bizarre avec l'homogénéité du
rayonnement fossile c'est que ce
rayonnement nous provient de différentes
régions or d'après le modèle du Big Bang
ces régions n'ont jamais pu être en
contact par le passé alors comment elle
pourrait s'être homogénéisée ça peut
vous paraître étrange qu'on dise que
certaines régions de l'univers n'ont
jamais été en contact les unes avec les
autres mais on va éclairer un peu ce que
ça veut dire pour ça parlons de la
notion d'univers observable
je vous ai dit qu'on ne savait pas a
priori si l'Univers était fini ou infini
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que à l'heure
actuelle nous on a accès qu'à une partie
de l'univers ce qu'on appelle notre
univers observable
comme il s'est écoulé que 13,8 milliards
d'années depuis le Big Bang on ne peut
observer que des objets dont la lumière
a eu le temps de nous parvenir il existe
dans l'univers des objets comme des
galaxies qu'on ne peut pas voir car leur
lumière n'a pas encore eu le temps
d'arriver jusqu'à nous et la taille de
l'univers observable dépend évidemment
du temps qu'il s'est écoulé depuis le
Big Bang il y a 10 milliards d'années
l'univers observable était plus petit
que ce qu'il n'est aujourd'hui si on
avait été là il y a 10 milliards
d'années avec le matériel nécessaire et
bien on aurait pu observer que les
objets situés à au maximum 3,8 milliards
d'années-lumière et ça veut dire que si
ensuite pendant 10 milliards d'années on
était restés là à observer l'univers et
bien on aurait vu peu à peu apparaître
de plus en plus de galaxies au fur et à
mesure que leur lumière nous parvenait
et que notre région d'univers observable
grossissait
et en faisant ça on se serait rendu
compte que les galaxies qui nous
apparaissaient au fur et à mesure
n'étaient pas différentes des autres
qu'on connaissait déjà et c'est là que
se trouve le paradoxe au moment où de
nouvelles galaxies nous apparaissent
c'est le tout premier contact entre
leurs zones d'univers et la nôtre et par
contact j'entends le fait d'échanger des
photos c'est le minimum si on veut
somogénéiser par exemple en échangeant
du rayonnement électromagnétique et donc
malgré l'absence de tout contact
préalable ces galaxies semblent venir
d'une zone d'univers totalement
semblable à la nôtre comment expliquer
ça comment se fait-il que des régions
puissent être à ce point semblable sans
être jamais vu et donc sans avoir pu
homogénéiser pourquoi l'univers est-il
si homogène alors qu'il ne devrait pas
bien nous voilà donc au total avec deux
problèmes du modèle classique du Big
Bang pourquoi l'univers est-il si plat
et pourquoi est-il si homogène et bien
l'inflation cosmique c'est une théorie
qui prétend résoudre à la fois l'un et
l'autre de ses problèmes alors voyons
comment ça fonctionne
[Musique]
regardons la question de l'homogénéité
de l'univers on a vu que ce qui pose
problème c'est la similarité apparente
de région qui pourtant d'après le modèle
du Big Bang n'ont jamais été en contact
par le passé et si elles n'ont jamais pu
être en contact c'est notamment parce
que plus on remonte dans le passé plus
l'expansion était forte tout à l'heure
je vous ai représenté l'évolution de
notre zone d’univers observable mais
sans montrer l'impact du mouvement
d'éloignement des galaxies alors
refaisons ça mais un peu mieux prenons
une galaxie située à 10 milliards
d'années-lumière de nous c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on voit cette galaxie et
que la lumière qui nous parvient d'elle
a été mise il y a 10 milliards d'années
elle est donc dans notre zone observable
et réciproquement
maintenant remontons dans le passé pour
faire ça on va utiliser la courbe
d'expansion de l'univers si on remonte
dans le passé certes cette galaxie était
plus proche de nous mais notre bulle
univers observable était aussi plus
petite donc un moment donné dans le
passé nous n'étions pas encore en
contact par exemple il y a 12 milliards
d'années la distance entre nous et elle
n'était que de 2 milliards
d'années-lumière mais il s'était écoulé
moins de 2 milliards d'années depuis le
Big Bang donc à l'époque on ne la voyait
pas encore
alors on pourrait se dire oui mais si on
remonte au tout tout début là très
proche du Big Bang toutes les régions de
l'univers étaient proches les unes des
autres non et ben non même si on remonte
au premier instant il n'y a pas de
contact possible entre ces deux régions
l'univers et la raison c'est que plus on
remonte dans le passé plus l'expansion
était forte on voit que la pente était
plus raide au début et si on zoomet on
verrait quelque chose de ce genre
l'expansion de l'Univers a commencé très
fort éloignant immédiatement toutes les
zones d'univers les unes des autres sans
qu'elles aient le temps de se voir et
c'est seulement parce que l'expansion se
ralentit que les deux zones d'univers
finissent un jour par pouvoir établir un
premier contact on se trouvant pour la
première fois dans la zone observable
l'une de l'autre en conclusion on ne
peut pas expliquer que l'Univers nous
apparaisse si homogène aujourd'hui et
c'est à cause de la forme de l'expansion
qu'on voit ici
pour résoudre ce problème il faudrait
par exemple changer l'allure de la
courbe au tout début plutôt que d'avoir
une expansion qui démarre à fond il
faudrait par exemple commencer doucement
pour que tous homogénéise bien puis une
fois que c'est fait avoir ensuite une
période de forte expansion
on voudrait une courbe plutôt de ce
genre avec ici une période très courte
et très forte de dilatation et c'est ça
qu'on appelle l'inflation si on avait ça
ça pourrait expliquer que l'univers soit
si homogène aujourd'hui
et outre la question de l'homogénéité
une période d'inflation de ce genre
résoudrait aussi la question de
l'univers plat alors je vous passe les
détails mathématiques mais en gros une
période d'inflation violente aurait
provoqué un aplatissement monstrueux du
rayon de courbure de l'univers et c'est
ça qui expliquerait que l'univers soit
si plat aujourd'hui
bien ça sonne donc parfait cette
solution mais comment on fait pour
obtenir dans nos modèles une période
d'inflation de ce type
vous voyez la courbe on a besoin d'une
période d'accélération très forte de
l'expansion ici mais qui cesse pour
ensuite laisser place à la courbe
normale
or on connaît un moyen d'avoir une
expansion accélérée c'est exactement ce
qu'il se passe avec la fameuse énergie
sombre vous savez l'expansion accélérée
qu'on peut observer aujourd'hui et qui
va se poursuivre elle est provoquée par
une très faible densité d'énergie sombre
alors ça va prendre des milliards
d'années avant de se voir mais en fait
on est dans une croissance exponentielle
on est juste au tout tout début de
l'exponentielle et donc ce dont on
aurait besoin pour avoir la forme de la
courbe qu'on veut au début c'est une
sorte d'énergie sombre énorme mais très
temporaire et qui s'éteignent rapidement
au bout d'un court moment on peut être
plus précis que ça dans la description
de ce qu'on veut exactement on sait que
pour expliquer l'homogénéité de
l'ensemble de l'univers observable la
période d'inflation devrait provoquer
une croissance d'un facteur 10 puissance
27 en un temps très court environ 10
puissance moins 33 secondes donc oui on
veut un truc très très court et très
très pentu ici et ce qu'il faut c'est
justifier d'où viendrait cette sorte
d'énergie sombre temporaire
et c'est ce que propose le modèle de
l'inflation ce modèle postule qu'il
existe un champ quantique on le surnomme
l'inflaton dont l'énergie aurait été
responsable de l'inflation primordiale
on ne connaît pas la nature exacte de
cette hypothétique inflatante et il
existe de nombreux modèles qui tendent
d'imaginer ce qu'ils pourraient être et
comment il évoluerait pour provoquer la
bonne inflation puis s'éteindre ensuite
le souci c'est que si on n'a pas de
condition plus strictes c'est un peu
open bar il y a plein de modèles
différents qui pourraient faire
l'affaire alors comment discriminer et
trouver le bon et même comment avoir une
preuve expérimentale que ce scénario
d’inflation est le bon et bien on peut
le faire grâce aux fluctuations
quantique de ce champ en effet ces
fluctuations qui existaient à l'époque
de l'inflation aurait été à l'origine
des fluctuations du rayonnement fossile
vous vous souvenez toutes ces très
légères inhomogénéités de température
qu'on voit ici
et en analysant les fluctuations du
rayonnement fossile on peut mettre des
contraintes sur les modèles d'inflation
ayant une chance de coller à la réalité
alors voyons comment ça se passe il y a
essentiellement deux paramètres à
surveiller qu'on note respectivement NS
et R le jeu est donc le suivant si vous
proposez un modèle d'inflation vous
devez calculer les valeurs théoriques de
NS et de R qui sont associés à votre
modèle et ensuite vous regardez dans les
fluctuations du rayonnement fossile si
ces valeurs ont une chance de coller à
la réalité d'après les derniers
résultats
issus du satellite planque la valeur de
NS est de
0,9665 plus ou moins 0,0038 vous voyez
que c'est assez précis alors par contre
la quantité notée R et bien on n'arrive
pas à en estimer une valeur on sait
juste qu'elle ne peut pas être plus
grande que 0,1 mais on n'en sait pas
plus et en particulier on ne peut pas
avec les données dont on dispose
affirmer avec certitude que R existe
qu’il est différent 0
il y a quelques années une collaboration
expérimentale appelée bicep2 avait
annoncé en grande pompe à voir mesuré
enfin une valeur strictement positive
pour r ce qui aurait constitué une
preuve très forte de l'idée d'inflation
cosmique et alors ils avaient fait la
totale en communication et notamment
débarquer à l'improviste avec du
champagne chez André lindeu qui est un
des théoriciens pionniers de l'inflation
en tout ce petit monde se voyait déjà
avec le prix Nobel sauf que la
découverte a fait cheat c'est avéré que
leur mesure était entachée de bruit et
que finalement rien ne prouvé que R soit
bien strictement positif à ce jour on a
donc pas de mesures expérimentales qui
corroboreraient de façon indiscutable le
modèle de l'inflation et permettrait de
mettre des contraintes plus fortes pour
comprendre sa nature et son origine mais
l'idée semble quand même tellement
simple et séduisante et elle permettrait
comme on l'a vu d'expliquer à la fois la
platitude et l'homogénéité de l'univers
l'inflation fait donc partie du
paradigme actuel en cosmologie même si
ces questions on reste comme toujours
ouverte avant de conclure un dernier
élément on a vu que les éventuels
fluctuations quantiques de l'inflaton
pouvait avoir servi de point de départ
au fluctuation qu'on observe dans le
rayonnement cosmologique comme des
perturbations initiales qui auraient été
amplifiées par l'expansion de l'Univers
et bien c'est perturbations pourraient
aussi expliquer la façon dont se
répartisse les galaxies et donc la
structure à grande échelle de l'univers
mais ça ce sera pour un prochain épisode
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si ce
contenu vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne rien rater des
prochaines vidéos avec la déferlante des
vidéos shorts sur Youtube ça devient de
plus en plus difficile pour moi de faire
émerger mes nouveaux épisodes même pour
les abonnés donc n'hésitez pas à mettre
la cloche et j'espère qu'avec tout ça on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo à bientôt
[Musique]